hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
it's been a long time since we've heard
anything about the spider-man far from
home trailer it was originally reported
that it was supposed to show in early
December this was due to the fact that
the trailer was officially rated and
they don't normally do this unless the
trailer is going to be shown very soon
and what happened was they were
originally planning on showing the
trailer online at the same time they
showed the trailer at Comic Con
experience in South Paolo Brazil and
what ended up happening is Sony decided
to delay the release of the trailer
online they did decide to show the
trailer at the Comic Con experience in
Brazil and the fans had nothing but
amazing things to say about the trailer
but then the online release sort of went
dark and we didn't really hear much more
about it for a very long time but now
Daniel RPK over at Super bro movie says
that he has exclusively learned that the
first official look at spider-man far
from home will release on January 15th
that's Tuesday next week daniel has been
right about many big trailer drops in
the past including the Captain Marvel
trailer showing during the football game
and the big one The Avengers and game
trailer so he has a lot of credibility
and a great track record of knowing when
these trailers are going to come out
keep in mind things can always change
but right now it's scheduled for January
15th Tuesday of next week right now
based on everything that we know about
the trailer from what we've heard from
the people who saw it at the Comic Con
experience in Brazil we will be getting
our first up-close and personal look at
Jake Gyllenhaal's character Mysterio
also getting a first look at some
elementals as well this will also be the
first movie happening after the events
of Avengers endgame so it'll be
interesting to see the overall feel of
the movie from this trailer but based on
what people said who saw the trailer at
CC XP there is no talk of Avengers
endgame at all or the events of Avengers
infinity war so I'm super excited to see
what this trailer has in store for us so
there you have it the spider-man far
from home trailer is expected to release
online next Tuesday January 15th let me
know how excited you are and what you're
most excited to see in the spider-man
far from home trailer let me know in the
comments down below
and I'm still giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet if you would like to
enter the giveaway for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero also be sure to
subscribe if you'd like to stay up to
date on everything relating to
spider-man far from home Avengers in
game in all things Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]